whether an rts something will launch on
pc first and not come to the the xbox
console maybe come late it'll come but
it'll come later like what are your
thoughts on that
yeah it really depends on each
individual title so in some cases like
you said with rts's as an example those
games are more traditionally thought of
as pc games and it's really important to
land them authentically on pc um but
then you know gears tactics is a great
example where it launched on pc and then
it came to console later you know part
of that is sometimes there's design work
that needs to happen when you think
about like input modalities and keyboard
and mouse versus controller you know
sometimes you kind of have to rework the
actual design of the game to make it
more accessible on controller
we do support keyboard and mouse on
console but it's also not necessarily
like a primary way that a lot of people
tend to use their console right so it's
like you know we want to make sure that
when a game releases on console it feels
very authentic and native to that
experience similarly when a game
launches on pc we want it to be
authentic there so sometimes it's just
the timing uh you know flight sim's
another good example where we launched
flight sim originally on pc then we
brought it to console and then you know
then when you think about bringing it to
cloud it's really about you know how do
we make sure whether it's streaming to a
pc a console or a mobile device it's
still that same great gaming experience
so it's all experience led um and yes
our goal is to provide the best catalog
of games wherever you choose to play and
if a game is available across multiple
devices things like cross progression
are super important so that you can you
know maybe start playing on a console
and then pick up and go on your pc and
then go back to your console because
it's really about celebrating you and
the franchises that you love
and just giving you more opportunities
to play yeah i agree i think that um
definitely makes sense on on that level
also i did want to fall back on the
update in reference to development tools
because some things that we do see is
you know we want for example like a game
like the ascent or or something like
that it came out on pc you know we see
sometimes there may be some performance
issues so it do you feel a lot of that
may be a result of uwp and not getting
over to windows 11 and some of this will
help alleviate some of the issues some
people may be having with pc game pass
as well as you know other tools that you
might be trying to provide to help
improvements for developers so that the
pc experience is kind of matching
performance wise what the console
experience is getting
i'd say for every update that we
released to gamers we probably released
the same number if not more updates to
developers you know and i think if you
look at any console generation or just
any you know period of time if you look
at the games at the beginning of
generation versus at the end of the
generation they're just night and day
different because developers have gotten
better with the tools we've gotten
feedback from developers on how we can
make the developer experience better for
them
also developers learn how to take
advantage of some of these next-gen
capabilities or you know maybe it's
it'll take them a year or two to get
their engine moved over and now all of a
sudden for you know the next three or
four iterations of the game they have a
solid foundation both at the platform
layer and at the game engine layer and
now it's really about pushing the
boundaries as far as they can go so like
for me as an example i probably spend at
least half of my time with game
developers from all around the world
whether it's our first party studios or
third party studios and just like we
were talking about kind of reflecting on
the the year of launch we've done
similar conversations with a lot of our
development partners of like hey what do
you how do you feel about the platform
where are areas that we can improve and
kind of push the boundaries and if you
look at the games this holiday you know
the games this holiday you look at a
game like forza horizon 5 or you know
you guys were talking about halo you
know part of that is they've had more
time with the hardware they've had more
time with the tools and we've had the
opportunity to respond to that feedback
to just make it the best place to
develop games and that ultimately leads
to better games for gamers all around
the world awesome awesome yeah love love
the improvement in the space the
continued you know dedication to
improving there and again i'm always
excited when i see those those uh pc
updates because my pc lords they always
hit me up get it at it and the biggest
thing that i really enjoy is just how
you order that it's like we want to
tailor the experience for a pc crowd to
the pc crowd and the console crowd to a
console crowd because i feel like a lot
of people feel like they need to be the
same and that's just not realistic like
they they're two different demographics
of gamers good point good point let's
move on and get right into this back
compat program fps boost you know you
guys made a huge splash this week
70 plus xbox 360 games i think um also
with auto hdr
uh resolution bumps fps boost of 11 new
titles and then i believe 26 more titles
from the existing library fps booths
also rolled out on the cloud gaming
through their game pass ultimate and i
want to read the uh the xbox wire
statement from um program lead backup
lead peggy lowe she said while we
continue to stay focused on preserving
and enhancing the art form of games we
have reached the limit of our ability to
bring new games to the catalog from the
past due to licensing legal and
technical constraints thank you for
being the part big part of this journey
with us so first of all jason salute to
the entire team you know the amazing
efforts on game preservation the
enhancements been absolutely amazing you
know i've been seeing this program
through the infamous infancy days in
2015 a shout out i'll be remiss if i
don't shout out to the late great club
late he's still live built still well
as if bill still was going shout out to
bill still up
the great wall you know when i remember
talking to him about the program and
just being how amazed of not having the
physical hardware inside right and then
learning about virtualization and to now
you know i'm out out here playing my
beloved uh 50 cent blood in the sand
right now
you know shout i went and got my disc
out yeah exactly i got i spoke it into
existence so defining duke with my boy
maddie plays what's going on with you
though
like really
jason let me tell you with this guy
right now i don't know what's going on
with what he's doing because they're
calling me the swami right now i don't
know
swabby bitty is actually
he has to be the enforcer because he's
sliding his little note under somebody's
blood and these people that's why i
wanted to have you on because let me
slide you a note because
let's get the real question what's 50
cent blood that's saying for me jason
was it for me
[Laughter]
a lot a lot of people signed a lot of
notes
i felt that
[Laughter]
it's okay man because you know i hit up
a couple months ago you know i was like
you know you need to put that favorable
anniversary 60 frames patch on there too
[Music]
two for one two three they're fabled too
like
i'm hoping
my hopes and my prayers for my my
beloved fable
[Music]
tremendous updates obviously again the
fable series backs pain dead spaces you
know i was playing elder scrolls
oblivion at 60 and it just it just hit
crazy it's different it is different so
i do have a miss i have to ask the
question that a lot of people are asking
this amazing this program is you know
many want to know but now back compat
you know kind of coming to an end for
new games being added right
will any existing back compact games
that haven't received fps boost and
resolution most will those still
continue to get enhancements
yeah i mean there's a there's a couple
things i'll say here so first i mean the
team's been working on that release of
new vacuum pad titles for more than a
year now
it was a lot it was definitely a law
jason
and part of that was we knew the 20th
anniversary was going to come and we
basically said like what is our ultimate
wish list of titles like if we you know
could wave a magic wand even though
people claim we're wizards we're not
really wizards we don't have magic wands
no
um but but i mean we literally started
with a list of hundreds of games that
we're like okay this is our fantasy list
this is the the list of titles and a lot
of that really came from the community
you know there's great members of the
community that would ping me on social
media every day or people who people
would read every
and then like people would collate lists
and they prioritize them for us and
whatnot so we started with a list of
hundreds of titles that we wanted to
bring to the program and you know to be
honest every title is a challenge you
know whether it's a technical issue
whether it's a licensing issue in some
cases the publishers and the developers
who made the game don't even exist
anymore so there's like a lot of slew
thing that we have to go do to even find
out who we need to get approvals and
rates from and whatnot right and
throughout the entire year that hundreds
of games really kind of winnowed down
into the list of games that we have here
so when we talk about you know we've
kind of reached the limit of our ability
to add new titles to the program trust
me if there's a game that you wanted
added to the program we've tried and in
some since we've actually tried for
years to bring some of these games of
the program and i'll say some of the
titles that are actually in this batch
we've actually been working on for years
to get the right things and some of
these memes i never thought we'd get the
right approvals or we'd be able to kind
of overcome some of these hurdles so us
this was really about a love letter to
the community and really kind of
respecting all the history that people
have um so that's why you know obviously
it's disappointing that we can't add
more titles to the program uh but at the
same time too i can honestly say the
team has gone above and beyond and they
were able to get titles that i would
never i never thought we would be able
to add to the program good at it yeah
so i got a question for you jason
what is that biggest game that you
yourself like to personal you ain't
coming you coming like this was coming
to the program yourself wanted that over
it
you
you know it was it was a personal goal
for you for to get it to the backers
compatible list for you
so i can't call out any individual
titles but i will say i will say there
were certain titles uh that the team
worked extremely hard on for multiple
months uh and they came through very
late in the game uh because you know we
knew it would be disappointing if we
couldn't get this game or that game out
um and you know there's one or two that
we've tried really really hard uh and
ultimately they fell out at the very end
but there was definitely some that were
able to save and include in this batch
but i can't really talk about specific
titles because like i said every title
is a unique challenge and they have a
unique set of things um and that's why
it takes so much work to bring some of
these games forward yeah yeah
one specific title that i for me i know
probably was hard to bring forward was
advent rising from from the 4g xbox in
one day
again those guys don't exist anymore
right so to see that game the thing
about admin rising was that it was
supposed to be this humongous sci-fi
epic
three games like you know written by
orson scott
like
exactly
to see advent rising there to be able to
play it um it was it was something
special because i'm like i never in my
life thought i'd see this game again
it's over it's done
and to see that game and to put the game
on and the resolution is through the
roof right obviously it doesn't have
frame rate boost because it probably
would have broken a million different
things in that game
but
to see the resolution bump and see that
game and to still be able to kind of
you know
the the strive for epicness in that game
bro like the scope of this game just
looking at it now and this game is a 15
year old 16 year old game
um so like yo i don't know how much
money i spent this past this is the 15th
just going scrubbing through
specifically ogx box right because 360 i
love those games but they feel more
modern like there's certain ones i'm
going to get absolutely but the og ones
to see them on there like i grabbed
ditto live three that was my launch game
i launched dave
[Music]
yeah so
so jumping off to that jason right
obviously
back compat and it's for in this form
you guys have talked about hey it's it's
done we've kind of reached the extent of
what we're gonna do um now thinking
about cloud and
and what cloud sort of
enables you guys to do and then recently
also
phil had an interview with with axios
where he was talking about more about
hey
we need to get on board with this legal
emulation if we want to preserve our
industry right and phil doesn't say
things just to save them
so and i know you know i obviously i
said
back compat in this form is probably
mostly done
is there a future where we could
possibly see
emulation of these console environments
just in the cloud even if you can't
apply like the frame rate boost or the
the resolution boost because it'll break
the game but the possibility to emulate
these platforms as they were in the
cloud and just allow
access to basically the entire library
of removing anything that has licensing
issues or whatever the case may be
is that a possibility in the future
yeah i mean what i'll say is like game
preservations and the dna of team xbox
you know and i think the cloud's an
interesting scenario that you bring up
because i was talking to somebody
earlier this week and trust me when
somebody was writing an xbox 360 game or
an og xbox game they were definitely not
thinking that 15 20 years in the future
this game's gonna be running in a data
center being streamed down to a mobile
device like it and like that's the
important thing is like we have this
great library we have this great kind of
catalog of games from our past and it's
really about how do we enable more
people to play these games you know you
bring up advent rising you know like one
that i heard a ton of feedback on was a
toadie
you know
and like so many people have these fond
memories of this and like did we know
we're gonna be able to bring that back
no but you know we went in and we
figured it out and now to have that
actually available and then i think the
other thing too like cog mentioned you
know being able to enable fps boost on
these games running in the cloud once
again not only do we want these games to
be playable we want them to be playable
in more places and better than ever
before so like there's a lot of
opportunity here and you know i
definitely appreciate phil's kind of uh
clarion call for the industry because
you know back when these games were
written on the original xbox or on the
xbox 360 we didn't have this notion of
forward compatibility and like when we
think about like certain contracts or
licensing agreements or even like i've
had experiences in my past where like we
wanted to go rebuild a game from like 10
years ago we don't we don't even have
the tools to be able to build those
games anymore let alone you know enhance
them and remaster them and
i think as an industry we've definitely
learned a lot we've definitely heard a
lot from the community and a lot of the
things that the team has developed and
the processes that they've developed are
really informing how we build games
today with an eye towards how do these
games live 10 15 20 years in the future
so there's a lot of opportunity here and
the team's got some really exciting
things that they're working on
uh but like i said you know since we
started with this wish list of like
every game that we ideally would like to
bring to the program there's just some
games that unfortunately we haven't
found a way to be able to come uh
overcome some of these hurdles we're
trying to take those learnings as we
think about the future you know we get
sure now i guess the because the the
consensus i heard the feeling i got from
the community was you know
obviously we love the work that's been
done
back and pat so many games we understand
the challenges right we understand that
some things licensing say even something
from a technical standpoint but i guess
the second part people were nervous
about was fps boost because like yo we
like is fps boost done like is it no
more fps so like can you provide clarity
to the fps boost uh portion of the
program
yeah so right now we have more than 130
titles that we've been able to
successfully fps boost um and we're
always looking at new ways that we can
enhance titles whether it's resolution
increases frame rate improvements things
like auto hdr
so i'll say right now with the existing
technique that we have with fps boost
we've tried plenty more than 130 titles
okay and in some cases the vast majority
of the game works great but then we find
a game breaking bug like 80 of the way
through and like when those come up a
lot of times we sit there and the team
does everything they can to try to
figure out how do we get over that but
in some cases like you know there was
one game specifically where there's a
critical moment very late in the game
where an event would not trigger because
we're running it at this higher uh
frame rate and at that point in time
like we're kind of blocked there so i
think with our existing technique uh you
know we've enhanced a whole series of
xbox one games with this release we
figured out how to fps boost from some
360 nog titles but you know we've we're
going to continue to look for new
opportunities and new ways that we can
enhance titles but we don't have
anything in the immediate future just
because once again we always treat these
titles as a black box so we try to push
the titles further than they can but
we're always looking for new ways to be
able at the platform layer to enhance
these games and in some cases it works
on a subset of titles in other cases
like auto hdr it works on the vast
majority of the portfolio so something
we're continuing to investigate it's
just uh you know right now i think we're
kind of finding where some of the
limitations of our current technique is
well maybe one day the greatest 900p
game of all time right son of rome you
know maybe
maybe one day